you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at another game between alpha zero
playing on the white end and stockfish
so what opening do we have in this one a
d4 based opening to be a bit more exact
we're working with a Queen's Indian
defense Black's prepared to fianchetto
Queen Bishop let's sneak in one more
move g3 now of the 10 games that are out
there between these two 4 of them saw
efore based openings the other six d4
based openings the six d4 based openings
all arrived at this exact position and
in every game alpha zero is playing with
white what's one quick note we can take
away from this well when confronted with
the Queen's Indian defense alpha zero is
a fan of Fein Kettering the King bishop
the LightSquared bishop s-- competing
now for the longest diagonal vision
before check Bishop d2 and what to do
with this guy in this game the bishop
drops back to e7
now this little finesse investment of
two Tempe with the dark square Bishop
one has black accomplished well it's
known this guy here on d2 is not so well
placed I can forget about fee and
ketamine the D 2 square is now occupied
the neither Knight can make use of that
square sometimes this would be desirable
in this opening to reinforce c4 that can
be sensitive now that the bishop has
gone elsewhere and one final note the
queen is now not able to see along the D
file as clearly sometimes why would like
to play d5 and have the Queen there to
defend that square directly not now with
the bishop in the way play continues
with Knight c3 keep in mind this is a
strength in the game a pawn duo needs to
be challenged at some point and black
can do that at this moment with d5 let
me show what would happen after d5 this
isn't terrible for black but I just want
to highlight that the ratio in the
center has changed its now tipping in
White's favor 2 to 1 black doesn't want
that and so first preface is d5 with c6
what's the difference well after E 4 and
d5 now black is prepared to me C takes
d5 with C takes d5 and there you go 2 to
2 ratio in the center is maintained now
this is an interesting moment in the
game
a common continuation here in reply to
d5
there's a thread on e for a common
continuation is to capture on d5 with
the e pond and after the recapture with
the C pawn of course that was the point
to followup with Knight to e5 to occupy
e5 with a piece a night in with this
move to pieces or helped the knight and
the bishop alpha0 has a different idea
in mind this continuation is popular as
an example the 2014 World Chess
Championship match saw this in Game five
Anand with white against Carlsen most
recently July of 2017 to top level
players 2700 plus players played this
line okay
alpha zero has a different ID in mind at
this moment here what is it
'if I've occupy e5 with a punt
grab some space and do so with a punch
play continues with the nighty form
castle's it's at this stage that
stockfish now goes pawn hunting
Bishop to a6 follows upon on c4 is now
struck out twice and in a pin he's going
down
b3 is the reply before black and capture
on c4 and black needs to address the
pressure on e4 so the Knights are
exchanged and only then D takes c4 one
more move B form I'd like to pause for a
moment this is the first position that
really captured my attention when I
cycled through this game for the first
time just you know skimming through it I
thought what is going on
white is doubt not only is white down
upon but white has to now contend with
let me sneak one more move in there
white has to now contend with a
protected past pond that's not just any
pond okay if you're I mean if you're not
experienced with the game do just know
that a protective past pond is a great
asset in the game especially in endgame
now it's I know we're far away from an
endgame stage this is still a a rich
middle game position but come endgame
phase King and pawn endgame this is
basically like a win for black having a
protected past prawn so only 13 moves in
White's down upon and it's a protected
past pawn of all pawns where is the
compensation here well in order to
understand what white gets in return we
have to observe the pawn structure this
gives us a lot of information the
structure will influence the quality of
the pieces so we need support we need to
observe some things here the pawns that
are fixed in particular for black b5 c4
e6 and you might as well chalk up the c6
pawn is fixed as well where is he going
there's a nice grip over d5 you could
never successfully play the c5 move not
at least without giving the pawn back ok
these pawns what do they all have in
common well they're on light squares
guess who's influenced this clown on a6
what's his future okay
this diagonal this diagonal this
diagonal no to all three I don't see
what he does for the rest of the game
that's the compensation White has space
with the e5 pawn and this board is soon
to be cut in half and white is going to
be able to attack on the kingside and
show that my light-square bishop his
presence is felt your bishop is
non-existent let's see how play
continues Knight d2 okay so the knight
is heading for efore he can't make use
of e5 he's going to d2 in any form black
castles 92 Bishop b7 queen g4 notice the
nice freedom of movement White has with
this space having the e4 available for
not only the knight but will soon I will
later see that the the bishop can make
use of that square as well the Queen has
a nice home on g4 opposite the King
painting upon it's important to note
that it's not only the light square
bishop who is influenced in this
position that's that's the clearest
piece to see being influenced but it's
also important to recognize that the
bishop on e7 there are so many squares
taken away from the dark square bishop
as well in the queen
what is her productive role going to be
okay the only productive role I can see
is with a knight circling into the d5
square okay let's see how white
addresses this strong post on d5 97
Knights e5 okay a little fork here the
Knights are exchanged now if the nights
are not exchanged here I'm not sure
exactly how play would continue a try is
to play Queen c7 avoid the knight
exchange and then circle in here but in
the game we have the knight exchange
straight away and the continuation is d
takes d4 takes knight so the board is
now cut in half we have one open file
but
the same situation is present the bishop
the light-square bishop what is he going
to do this space is just so great that
White has this kingside space the
protected past pawn is surprisingly
enough not a not an inconvenience to
white the bishop on c3 has that
responsibility to make sure he doesn't
bolt for a touchdown and the bishop also
has some influences well on the kingside
ok this if if black tries to you know
gain a little space or crack things open
on the kingside with let's say f6 well
the bishop is there to help influence
that type of pawn break okay so it's not
just a strictly defensive pieces what
I'm getting at he's not just there to
keep a watchful eye over the protected
past pawn no he has some Kings side
influence as well especially now that
the D pun has captured on c5 okay so
things open up a little bit on the Queen
side the a pawns are exchanged one rook
is exchanged and now the first active
moved by black Queen to d3 okay well
it's not fun to have to babysit the
bishop but rook to c1 soon this pressure
will be alleviated rook e8 and it's very
tempting to want to go in for Bishop b4
here but not straight away instead h4
this is a stabilizing move for who
exactly the Queen what do I mean by this
well if Bishop b4 is tried straight away
the Queen can be dislodged from her
defense of the bishop with h5 and if the
Queen moves we would have g5 she's
getting chased away from defending the
bishop white does not want a Queen
exchange here first it's h4 stabilize
the Queen post from these deflection
ideas and more long-term this is going
to be a battering ram at H pawn
looking to inflict some pawn weakness or
create some open file its first H form
and now the Queen runs home
okay this captured my attention for sure
why is why is black voluntarily
retreating without waiting for a first
Bishop to e form what would be a more
active move certainly a move like rook
to a2 in this position comes to mind
what would happen if rook a2 is played
well Bishop b4 and if black attempts to
exchange Queens with Queen to e2 white
will say at this point yeah you know I
will go for a queen exchange because in
the end guess who's going to get trapped
your rook
look at these bishops they are monsters
okay what squares are they not taking
away from the rook on e2 the rook is
dead in just a couple so the Queen in
this position runs back home Bishop b4
look at the squares the bishops are
taking away even if a rook occupies a
black rook occupies the D file the
bishops are killers there's no good
entry point for a black rook might as
well cancel out d6 as well black has two
squares to work with black is basically
playing on two ranks of the board white
is controlling six Queen c8 King g2 slow
steady progress for white basically
passing / nothing moves for black how do
you improve the pieces for black how do
you change the structure there's a good
way to change the structure what does
this mean black has to play within the
structure in the structures no good
Queen c7 follows queen h5 provoking some
weakness g6 is the best way to defend
he's not around to watch over the light
squares so the pawns need to have that
responsibility the bishop the dark
square bishop is at least around to
remedy the weaknesses now on f6 and h6
queen g4 light now has something to bite
out Bishop f8 h 5 so this little lift is
not providing a quick transfer to the
King side rook d8 open file but where
are the entry points they don't exist
Queen h4 Queen e7 and Queen f6 black
could exchange Queens but this only
makes life more difficult for team black
for example if Queen takes Queen
if you thought things were bad for the
the black pieces with the pawn on e5
they just get even worse now the pawn
now can takes control over two new
squares in black scam so what's what's
he going to do now okay these these two
feet that both bishops are dead this is
the only active piece the rook and he's
just been dancing you know he's kind of
flipping a coin do I want to go the a
file or the D file let's flip a coin one
piece is not going to be enough okay
there's no good coordination for black
whatsoever one active piece doesn't cut
it
White has three active pieces and soon
the Kings going to play an active role
or could play an active role in this
position with the Queen's off this is a
great thorn in black side a pawn on f6
this isn't a type of position where
you'd go oh I don't want this to happen
because I'd have double puns no upon an
f6 is of great value
so Queen ee8 in the game rook h1 rook d7
H takes G black
has to take away from the center taking
like this and pick your favorite way to
give me
so f takes g6 taking away from the
center
that makes this a bit sensitive Queen h4
Queen e7 like doesn't want a queen
exchange now ideas of sacrifices are
right around the corner
the Queen is a super piece tied in very
well with the bishop these three pieces
are playing this guy not so much but
that's soon going to change rook d8
Bishop to b2 okay can't go to d2 but now
with Bishop b2 he's looking to pivot on
c1 and then sneak in here and you can be
sure his presence will be felt cutting
in on this diagonal looking to pivot on
f6 that's a hole in blacks camp soon all
the white pieces will be attacking the
black King and guess who's not around
this guy he's garbage continuing Queen
f7 Bishop c1 and c3 you'll notice a
spike in the evaluation with this last
move
c3 it says roughly equal at depth 22 23
24 now and then after the c3 move a big
shift well I let this position sit for a
while until about depth 40 and other
moves instead of c3 like making a rook
move to d7 kind of a sit-in weight
approach which is basically all that
black has been able to do for many moves
now eventually result in a similar
evaluation of plus-one yeah of a similar
evaluation +1 so I would just like to
highlight some other continuation
besides c3 just to emphasize the type of
approach Y can take attacking the king
for example rook to d7 here rook d7
there's this idea of rook h4
let's say Bishop c8 Bishop gets active
let's say the rook comes over to a7
Queen to h3 so what is being set up here
let's just make one other passing move
just to illustrate this attacking idea
look at this situation perfect battering
the bishops knifing into the King
position and all of a sudden there is
this tactic to capture on g6 we're
seeing the point now with this little
rook lift to h4 what would black do here
taking what the pawn runs into mate
taking with the Queen at minimum runs
into rook to g4 and there goes the Queen
the short story here is that from this
position a sit and wait approach just
kind
dancing back and forth with the rook on
the a file of the D file or making a
bishop move allows white to slowly build
up to a point where a tactic is going to
occur some type of sacrifice on g6 is
right around the corner so black tries
to distract now setting the protected
past pawn into motion c3 in the game
Bishop e3
there's no rush worth picking up this
pawn the bishop finds a secure Square
all the squares on the D file are still
under control no great entry square for
the rook and at this stage white simply
drops back and scoops up that extra pawn
there's nothing that black can really do
to prevent this
the material has been restored and the
positives still remain of course for
teamwipe this great space advantage and
a terrible bishop
Queen d7
Rocsi one white wants to play Bishop g5
but that would give black an opportunity
to play Queen to d4 it's still good for
white but white wants to keep the
Queen's on for just a little bit more
so first secures the Queen position and
then Bishop g5 is serious threatening
the rook the Queen would be defended
this is the point with route to c1 the
Queen is defended so now this is a
threat Queen c7 in the game
notice what are these two pieces do
these are the only safe squares for the
major pieces and any move by them and
any move by the Queen of rook is a
demotion of that piece
Queen c7 Bishop g5 there's no in-between
shot of Bishop takes pawn hitting the
Queen because Bishop takes rook would be
hitting the black Queen rook FA
F form look at the transfer of the
bishop he's no longer needed on c3 to
defend against the past pawn he has
pivoted on b2 c1 g5 and he's eyeing up
f6 unlike blacks bad bishop we have
lights bad bishop outside of this pawn
chain and look at how active he is
looking to post-up on f6 next h6 Bishop
f6 follows dark square Bishop Sargon
Queen f7 rook a one Queen takes pawn
Queen takes Queen rook takes Queen
material is balanced or you see me
material is no longer balanced but look
at the activity of the white pieces rook
a seven Bishop takes pawn now it is
balanced and it's going to stay well
white is not going to give away and the
other pawns it's at this point that
white simply mops up basically all black
pawns in short order let's see how this
six this is accomplished ripped e7 King
F 2 white finds it much easier to
activate the king in this endgame and it
is related to this space it's related to
this one piece tying down two black
pieces it's like white is playing with
this free piece still even in this
simplified endgame G form Bishop c8 rook
a a rook c7 look at the giant not that
the black pieces are in King III h5
giving away upon doing something other
than that such as King g7 the bishop
plays to h5 and how do you untangle is
black eventually black will find himself
on
black will be in Zook swung for example
King f6 King e4 if the King moves the
white king improves and if the bishop
moves
we have checks that can be given King g7
rook to b8 King f6 it could even try
Brooke g8 yeah this would be the right
idea to flush the King away from f6 and
then sneak into e5 white will make
progress one way or the other so at this
point starts pitching some pawns in
order to grant the King some squares and
one by one these pawns are simply going
to fall C pawn is now gone and soon the
b-pawn will be following in this endgame
as well and not too long from now we're
gonna have team black throw in the towel
after move 68 Bishop to e2 black resigns
so if the game did continue this is just
one of the many ways they could have
finished straight to checkmate with a
king and rook versus a king just showing
that quickly not too many moves from now
again just one of many ways this game
could have finished so what more to add
with this one started you're protecting
us even though the last row was not the
most important feature in our game most
important was that the static structure
granted me a space advantage out of the
King side he was not only your life
squared
but also your dark-squared bishop and
queen whose mobility was negatively
influenced by my space advantage this
space permitted me the time to arrange
my two bishops such that they dominate
the whole board voluntarily entered into
this type of pony structure is known
throughout the Alpha universe for its
stupidity
you